hey guys mkbhd here back with another
high definition video and today we're
going to be taking a look at internet
explorer yes i didn't think i would be
saying this or ever doing a video about
this but today we have the newest
version of internet explorer 9 beta
which is actually a humongous
improvement over internet explorer 8 the
final version so just so you guys know
this yes is still in beta which means
it's not meant to be your full-time
browser but you certainly could go with
this option if you're still using
internet explorer eight so this is the
first page it greets you with you can
see it says welcome to a more beautiful
web you can see how it works and you can
see it's actually pretty much
broadcasting that fish tank test we
looked at back in our google chrome 7
video so basically i'm going to give you
guys a look over the overhaul of the
user interface what i like to call an
interface lift so we'll close out of
that here so you can see there's a whole
lot of screen space at the bottom and up
here next to the url bar there's a very
nice usage space which i could actually
get used to in something like chrome or
whatever who else
decides to adopt this you have the url
bar on the left hand side with back and
forward and your typical omni bar here
which you'll see with something like
google chrome then you have the x button
for stopping things and reloading then
you have your tabs here you can open a
new tab and you're presented with this
nice little most visited sites so you
can see this is the least active i've
only visited this once visited this once
and i've visited google a ton of times
so that's basically
how it'll sort your most viewed pages so
you can open a new tab that way all the
way on the right hand side here there's
your home button of course my home is
google.com ironically enough there's
also your favorites button typical
microsoft you can obviously obviously
obviously move it over to the left hand
side
with that button and close your
favorites here and it has a chrome like
tools button with that little wrench so
you can print and do all your different
things i really think this is a much
better implementation if you saw
internet explorer 8 there was a giant
area here where you would actually have
all your tools and things you wouldn't
be able to have them just behind one
little button right here just like that
so that's really nice
something else i want to show you guys
is that fish tank test if you remember i
did that in the chrome 7 video it did
perform relatively well not stunning but
certainly better than the last version
of google chrome so you can find this at
the link in the description along with
the download link to internet explorer 9
and i'll make sure i get it right this
time so you can see right off the bat
with the screen recorder going you can
see we're getting about 55 frames a
second with 20 fish which is very
impressive you're not going to get all
those frames see we max out at 60 frames
a second here we go to 50 fish with
hardware acceleration we still maintain
that 100 fish with hardware acceleration
or over 30 frames a second so this is
going to perform a lot better than
chrome 7. i never thought i'd say that
but it's actually really
basically with hardware acceleration
movements going on within your browser
and things like this are going to
perform much better so of course with
one fish we're going to get a ridiculous
frame count
something else we want to show you guys
is the acid 3 test a very popular test
of course by standard it'll bing search
everything
you can obviously well you can change
this to be google i haven't exactly gone
through the preferences yet you can go
to internet options just like you could
in the last version and i suppose you
can change that to google but i'm
actually fine with bing i don't have a
problem with it
so let's go ahead and uh check out the
acid three tests you saw the scrolling
bar up there
and it looks like we're going to be
stuck at an awkward 70 uh 95. i do
recall people saying in the chrome video
that they got 95 out of 100 and that was
just a quick little image rendering
problem somewhere you're not really
going to notice it in everyday browsing
but there is something to notice that
you're you're not going to get a hundred
out of a hundred
so like i said this is a much faster
version of this browser i'm going to go
ahead and exit out of it and actually
bring a shortcut over to our desktop so
you can see how fast it actually opens
up so here we go three two one
so it's actually pretty fast if you if
you ask me it's not quite at the speed
of chrome but it's definitely going to
force me to drop something like firefox
not to make any firefox fans mad out
there but that does take quite a bit
longer to open than internet explorer
and you gotta you gotta admit that's
that's something to to look up to so if
we go to youtube a site that we may
visit every day it's still not the
fastest browser out there but you can
tell it's got a whole lot more
enhancements especially in the user
interface side of things than internet
explorer eight so overall this is
definitely a thumbs up if you want to go
ahead and try this if you're still using
an older version of internet explorer
you can go ahead and upgrade to this
beta you won't have any problems so this
has been on a quick little overview of
microsoft's latest attempt at a decent
browser and i have to say they've done a
much better job than i had anticipated
but it's still not going to be bringing
me off my trusty google chrome just
throwing that out there alright so mkbhd
here with a video review of internet
explorer 9 beta talk to you guys in the
next video signing out peace
you